bonne après-midi mesdames messieurs ici
julie drolet bienvenue à initier rdi
alors on va revenir tout de suite sur
ces experts qui se sont réunis à plaster
rock au nouveau brunswick qui ont
recours à une on appuie sur une
explosion contrôlée du brûlage dirigé
pour tenter de mettre fin à l incendie
qui a commencé mardi soir lors du
déraillement d'un train qui transportait
des matières dangereuses du pétrole du
butane entre autres recchi landry et sur
place justement alors et qui explique et
nous justement le son est en train de
faire on le voit d'ailleurs c'est un
gros panache de fumée il a qui a
commencé depuis cette intervention
ben oui examen est exactement ça fait
peut-être le 10 ou 15 minutes donc des
experts embauchés par le canadian
national on décide provoqué une
explosion contrôlée dans un des trois
wagons qui se trouvent toujours sur les
rails
donc il dit là il y en a seulement trois
maintenant deux de ses wagons la
continue de brûler ce sont les deux
wagons dont on parle depuis ce matin le
qui brûlent à petit feu qui est qui
contenait du pétrole liquéfié il en
reste un troisième qui contenait le même
carburant qui n'avaient pas explosé
celui là était toujours intacte pour
sécuriser la scène on a décidé de
provoquer une explosion dans le
troisième c'est à dire quoi avec des
explosifs ou on a voulu faire un petit
trou dans le wagon pour permettre au gaz
de s'échapper rapidement et de brûler
rapidement pour sécuriser toute la scène
pour confier se retirer les trois
derniers wagons pour permettre aussi aux
citoyens et aux 150 résidents de price
trois qui ont été évacuées de rentrer à
la maison plus vite parce que sinon il
faut attendre que tout brûle à petit feu
salle et prend trop de temps donc on a
voulu en finir dans une heure tout
devrait brûler d'ici une heure donc des
pour permettre aux wagons par la suite
de refroidir d'environ trois heures les
experts devraient pouvoir se rendre sur
les scènes la scène sera sécurisé ils
pourront évaluer la situation et dans
les heures qui suivront probablement
retirer les wagons pour terminer donc le
nettoyage le but c'est de permettre aux
résidents de rentrer à la maison et de
rouvrir cette voie de transport des
marchandises qui est très importante
dans la région aussi est ce que ça veut
dire donc que les personnes évacuées
vont enfin pouvoir regagner pour de bon
leurs résidences personne ne sait
toujours pas un parce que les autorités
ont rencontré les résidents
en milieu d'après-midi ils ne l'auront
pas dit s'ils pourront rentrer
aujourd'hui il faut toujours évaluer la
situation voir si les mesures de
sécurité sont toutes prises s'il y a
toujours un risque s'il ya toujours des
dangers avant de leur permettre de
retourner à la maison on ne donne pas de
date non plus on ne sait pas si ça va
être aujourd'hui demain dans deux jours
on n'a aucune idée vraiment ce qu'on
nous dit par contre c'est qu'on
l'explosion provoquée aujourd'hui c'est
pour leur permettre de rentrer à la
maison plus vite mais sans le 100 m de
délai merci beaucoup ri qui va voir les